[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
nor is ever to think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast for two
brothers answer your questions give you
devious advice and bring you bald
excused from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon
John hey it's good to see you not
actually how you doing I'm doing well I
feel like we should probably just talk
about the elephant in the room though
you know is this the one where we're
gonna talk a lot about the size of dirt
yeah that is definitely one of the
elephants in the room I've been thinking
that it would be fun to play a game
where you and I say we're gonna talk
about the elephant in the room and then
we count to three and then we say what
we think the elephant in the room is but
unfortunately you kind of headed it off
by saying what you think the elephant in
the room is I've got I've got another
one I got another one if you if you want
to do it I've got another elephant in
this room okay ready one two three poo
avocado yeah the avocado thing is
another issue but I would argue that
Putin is a more pressing concern at
least in my own life to be the elephant
in the room is definitely Putin and we
need to be talking more about the DC
character universe Hank Marvel has been
absolutely usurped by DC in the last few
months the DC character universe has
gone completely bonkers between Paul
Manafort and Rik gates and Michael Cohen
I have never seen a storyline like this
in my entire life but let's move on to
the size of dirt lots and lots and lots
of people emailed us to correct us about
whether sand has a size sand definitely
has a size we're gonna post Riley's
diagram on the patreon but Riley wrote
Dear John and Hank I'm a graduate
student in soils research obviously we
should have just had Riley on as a guest
and in regards to your question about
infinite sand I would like to inform you
that sand is the mineral fraction of
soil that is between two and point zero
five millimeters in diameter when it is
weathered to a size below point zero
five millimeters 50 microns it is
considered silt and then below point
zero zero two millimeters it is clay at
least in the United States while those
are arbitrarily designated
classifications to describe soil texture
I would still say that no
there is not an infinite amount of sand
on earth I attached a handy dandy figure
for reference and this is a very handy
dandy figure it must be noted we'll post
it on the patreon but man there is
definitely a definition of sand and we
apologize to our friends and family for
failing to understand the depths of
passion that people feel well it's not
the size of sand it's important to have
classifications while you're doing this
kind of science the other thing that I
did not say avocado John I said earlier
last the last one we did together the
last episode we did together I called a
home that was made out of an off the
inside of an avocado and you lived
inside the avocado the avocado because
it would be a dome but I should have
said and I apologize to everyone for not
saying this the avocado Oh snow see I
still think avocado MS better I don't
know John avocado seems like the correct
answer to me and I I think that everyone
would agree in fact I'm just gonna go to
Twitter right now and I'm gonna ask
people what they feel about this and
we're gonna report about it later on in
the pod but John let's move on to a
question from our listener sure Hank
while you're tweeting I'll read you this
question it comes from Rachel she writes
dear John and Hank my husband and I are
going to Texas this week and there is a
dr. pepper museum in Waco
oh yeah Rachel I am aware that there is
a dr. pepper in one of the cities we'll
be visiting
I say we should go he says no how do I
convince him 23 flavors strong Rachel
all right Rachel listen up
I assume that Hank is still tweeting so
I'm gonna answer this question Rachel
you know with the official name of the
dr. pepper museum in Waco Texas is it's
called the dr. pepper museum and free
enterprise institute because its founder
a guy named foots Clements believed so
much in the free market that on top of
the dr. pepper museum he inserted this
weird free Enterprise Institute it is
totally worth going it is bonkers it is
bananas and also like to understand the
history of diet dr. pepper is to
understand the history of the United
States in the late 19th and 20th
centuries
I would argue that it is not just like a
good idea to go but it's vital and that
indeed no human life is complete until
it has visited the dr. pepper museum and
free enterprise institute or eco Texas I
am right on John's trajectory here I
think that if you are going on road
trips passing up things like the Museum
of dr. pepper is a huge mistake and
every time I have gone to a place like
this I've been very happy that I did it
I think you don't have to buy any
souvenirs or anything you just want like
have an experience just like I don't
care if you care about dr. pepper
somebody does and I like to see people
enjoying the thing that they enjoy and
also to sort of allow that to infect me
a little bit you'll be surprised by how
much you can sort of like allow yourself
to just get really obsessed with and
interested in something as let's admit
it trivial and maybe uninteresting as
the 23 of ingredients in dr. pepper but
hey it's nice it's nice to let that
happen to you sometimes I'm not gonna
push back too hard I'm just gonna note
that there are more than twenty three
ingredients in dr. pepper of course I
mean there's no way you can get a flavor
like dr. pepper with a mere 23
ingredients there are 23 different
flavors oh okay
and a number of and and those flavors
require more than 23 different
ingredient of course not least of all
the preservatives um John I've made a
huge mistake in that I did not include
and I apologize to everyone I did not i
included avocado and avocado but I did
not include avocado erm so I feel like I
feel like the results are just useless
now okay great let's move on to another
question forefront listeners and please
stop paying attention to Twitter in fact
if I could give you sort of one
overarching piece of advice but I have a
whole podcast now that I need to I need
to uphold if you want to ask another dr.
pepper question John because there's
more than one dr. pepper question
alright next dr. pepper question alright
this next question comes from Mary Ann
who asks dear Hank and John I have my
husband listen to the anthropocene
reviewed
to show him the awesomeness that is John
Green and how John can take something
seemingly mundane and turn it into a
beautiful statement about life instead
he took it as a persuasive argument for
drinking diet dr. pepper and now my
previously health-nut husband who hadn't
a carbonated drink besides kombucha in
over a decade knocks back a can of Diet
Dr Pepper every time he studies which is
every night John was the one who got him
hooked so can he persuade my husband to
stop drinking diet dr. pepper much
appreciated Maryann the librarian that
seems unlikely
oh that I'm gonna try to stop Mary Ann's
husband from drinking completely healthy
and delicious diet dr. pepper you're
right Mary Ann first off thank you for
being librarian I'm so grateful to all
librarians everywhere for getting books
into people's hands and for answering
difficult complicated questions from
people and for being like one of the
last places in the United States where
anyone can walk in and be treated
completely equally so thank you moving
on you're completely wrong about diet
dr. pepper your husband should be
drinking a diet dr. pepper at night at
least at least one eye I would recommend
between 2:00 and 4:00 myself but here's
the thing
kombucha is good for you it has a lot of
probiotics and I'm not telling you to
stop drinking kombucha but I am telling
you that it has more sugar in it and
Diet Dr Pepper which is a delicious zero
calorie drink some sugar John so this is
part of a bigger thing that I've been
thinking about in and I don't want to
take away from the excellent and organic
mention of your new podcast but
additionally I'm gonna bring up this
very organic mention of my new podcast
in which people have said to me on
Twitter oh I love delete this so much
it's brought me back to Twitter and I'm
using Twitter again and I'm like yeah no
but to be clear I I wrote a review of
diet dr. pepper for the anthropocene
reviewed because I want more people to
drink diet dr. pepper right yeah this is
a non this is not an unintended
consequence it is the intended
consequence and should be paid for by
dr. pepper I don't know that they should
be paying for it actually I feel like my
love for diet dr. pepper
might be complicated if they were paying
me that said I would definitely accept
their money also if we're throwing out
brands I love in addition to Lacroix
water I love Delta underrated almost
every time you hear about an airline
doing something horrible and stupid it's
not Delta the best tagline for Delta
ever it's just yeah well they should
they should be using that I mean like
over and over and what we find is that
it's probably better to pay the extra
twelve dollars to fly Delta alright this
next question comes from Melissa who
writes Dear John and Hank what should I
wear to Hamilton no oh my memento mori'
Alyssa uh what should you wear to
Hamilton I mean do you do people cosplay
cuz that seems like the right call yeah
I mean you could go hard Aaron Burr but
I would go I would go George the third I
would walk in Oh interesting just
wearing robes capes and a huge crown now
I don't want to take too much away from
your idea John but what if you cosplayed
as like kylo Ren like related oh that's
good that's gold you just walk in and
you're just green from head to toe
muscle suit on like tiny pants and you
are The Incredible Hulk I mean it's
pretty good it's pretty good yeah I I
think I think it's best okay alternately
what if you cosplay as somebody from the
18th century American story who isn't
featured in Hamilton that makes it that
makes it harder to identify you know if
you're like John Jay or something yeah
which is definitely something I have no
idea what that is
John Jay wrote some of the Federalist
Papers he's the person who wrote
Federalist Papers who isn't Alexander
Hamilton or Monroe I also don't really
know what the Federalist Papers are I
think that that's probably okay God
okay well I would argue the well okay
well that's let's move on this next
question comes from Sarah who asks dear
Hank and John I'm a second year
university student and exam season is
coming up I'm going to be super busy
studying
do I eat healthier than pop-tarts
Timmy's and kraft dinner with little to
no time or groceries any easy to make
healthy recipes learning about the brain
cerebellum oh that's a very good Sarah
great so very good uh what's a Timmy
Hank what's a tonight should I google
that yeah at Google Timmy yeah are they
Timmy's I mean first it seems from the
name like you'd be fine living off
Timmy's right uh maybe Timmy's is is tim
horton's oh is it like coffee it's just
like Canadian people refer to coffee as
a Timmy because it's Tim Hortons god
that can't be true oh just like all I'm
eating is a bunch of Timmy's by which I
mean cups of coffee maybe DS is like a
donut from Tim Hortons maybe I don't
know i typed in Timmy's and the first
result is a band and the second is Tim
Hortons so maybe they just mean anything
from Timmy's and any Tim Hortons item
which there must be something healthy at
Tim Hortons right Hank wouldn't you hear
about things like people in Canada
calling Donuts
Timmy's or possibly coffee Timmy's that
will we'll never know for sure do you
ever find yourself feeling as I do a
desperate urge like this desperate deep
desire to just become Canadian just to
like wake up tomorrow and like not have
to like learn the culture and like go
through the rigmarole of immigration and
in my case probably extra rigmarole due
to having been denied entrance to Canada
in 1995 do you ever just like want to
like go to bed and wake up and be like
oh I've lived for the last 20 years in
Canada and my kids are in Canadian
schools and everything is great and I
have I've been Canadian the halt exactly
like oh that the rest of it was a dream
that whole weird stuff about having to
participate in the DC character universe
that was all a fiction and I have been
Canadian this whole time yeah and then
you wouldn't we wouldn't have to be like
what the Frick is a Timmy and and is it
healthier or not we have no idea I when
I was in college so as to actually
answer your question when I was in
college I would make what you call kraft
dinner
Kraft macaroni and cheese and I would
put other things in it let cut up ham or
beans that doesn't make it heavier that
that felt like it was healthier because
there was protein and not just
carbohydrates and and skim milk well
what I would recommend is related thing
called a macaroni scramble and you can
put some proteins in there if you want
but you can also put tons of vegetables
in it I've made it with green beans I've
made it with green bell peppers and all
you really like you genuinely can just
like you don't even have to cook them I
mean you probably should cook them
technically but like yeah I'll just
throw it all in there together and I let
the like you know let everything boil
together sometimes I do it with a little
bit of onion which I know is gross but
that's just--that's own oh that's great
yeah Catherine calls this dish that you
are describing fancy mac fancy-man where
you make in one pot you make the Kraft
macaroni and cheese and in a pan you
throw a bunch of stuff and that can be
like like fresh vegetables or it could
even be like the like frozen vegetable
thing from the frozen section you can
just dump it in there and you put like a
bunch of spices into that and then you
mix the two together and you got fancy
mac and it's like macaroni and cheese
but there's some fresh something in it
right I actually I do that but I but I
do it grosser because I do it all in one
pot I don't do the pan yeah I just I
just let it boil whatever I mean the
truth is when you're in that situation
and you're studying like you know you're
studying neuroscience and just just get
just get through it man don't worry too
much don't worry too much about what
you're eating just do what you need to
do to get through it yeah Catherine and
I would off often when we first lived
together with just like onions chicken
peppers and oregano salt and you know
mix that together with whatever whatever
boilie noodle dish you could find
whether it was Lipton meal or craft or
whatever and and we did that for a solid
year two years of our of our
relationship and it's the same as
sustained us just fine alright Hank
let's move on to geopolitics our area of
expertise having
cooking how did this happen oh let's
move on to the other thing that we know
a lot about this question comes from
Kate who writes Dear John and Hank why
is it that other nations like Russia and
North Korea quote flex their muscles by
testing huge rockets and stuff like that
but I never hear about the United States
talking about testing weapons it's not
that I think we need to have the biggest
toys or anything I'm just mildly
concerned that other nations are gonna
bomb us and we won't be able to defend
ourselves Kate hmm Kate I have good news
yeah we have the biggest choice a we
have the biggest toys be if other
nations bomb us we will be able to
defend ourselves see we do flex our
muscles quite a bit you don't really
hear about the u.s. flexing our muscles
cuz it doesn't scare us yeah like we you
hear the news about the things that
scares us you don't hear them like if
you lived in one of the places that
might get bombed you would hear a lot
about the US as flexing its muscles and
that's like that's as simple as the u.s.
taking this like nine billion dollars
ship and just driving it another 7 miles
closer that's like that's the u.s.
flexing its muscles it's basically like
oh no I know and that when the ship
moves a little bit I know that now twice
you've said ship but it does not sound
that way a big boat ah yeah you have to
remember that the United States has most
of the world's aircraft carriers I don't
mean any other country we have most of
them and the way we flex our muscles is
by doing kind of wargames we go through
and we do these military exercises often
with our allies we do this a lot with
South Korea and that it in North Korea
is seen as very threatening and very
upsetting and as proof that the United
States and South Korea are planning an
invasion of North Korea so I think Hanks
right that the reason we don't hear
about that kind of stuff we don't do we
haven't been done nuclear testing in a
long time but we also to
need to because we've done a lot of it
including being remember the only nation
ever to use nuclear weapons in in
wartime or or on actual people and on
actual people right
I think Hank is absolutely right that we
don't hear about this stuff because it
doesn't scare us and in general
especially in a world of personalized
news feeds the world that we're living
in now almost all of the news that
penetrates is news that feels very novel
or surprising or concerning because
those are the things that we respond to
really deeply the stuff that we're more
likely to share the stuff that we're
more likely to read closely and that
therefore is the stuff that advertisers
want to advertise on which is therefore
the stuff that you know content
producers and content packagers want to
show us so you have to remember that
it's incredible I have a really
difficult time with this Hank like it's
really hard for me to remember that the
stories that I'm seeing are shaped by
who I am and what Google and Facebook
and Twitter know about me rather than
being like objectively the news yeah
well I mean that's always to some extent
but in the case like even you know when
the news was a very sort of solidified
thing we were talking about it from the
American lens and and I think that now
we have a more global view of things at
least and I'm able to follow people on
Twitter who are experts in international
relations with China or Korea and have
their take in my feed but that is a
choice that I have to consciously make
and but at least it's a choice that I am
able to consciously make whereas I don't
think that it always was that way it's
easy to forget that a hundred years ago
everybody's news basically came from the
people around them so if you lived in a
small town in America like you got your
news from the be like your preacher and
your or your or your local newspaper I
mean there were news yeah furs but I
understand your point and it's a good
one and I as you know my gut reaction to
finding out that the thing that I
believed was going to save us all is not
going to save us all is
to swing as far in the other direction
as possible and that is probably not the
right gut reaction so you're right it is
it the social Internet has allowed us to
hear from voices that we weren't hearing
from before and that's really important
and good yeah I think that I think that
we have a lot of learning to do
regarding how to live in this current
world
oh is it is it understatement week
welcome to understated week here on dear
Hank and John this next question comes
from moose who asks dear Hank and John
moose here vivid a bit of a depressive
episode and I'm encouraging him as a
friend to get some therapy and ask his
mother to help pay for it I've spoken to
her this is an offer that she's made
here's my question though I'm so glad
that many therapists offer reduced rates
for students and people who can't afford
more but how do they do this is there a
grant system to compensate therapists do
they write it off on their taxes how
does it possibly work that all these
professional people who need to earn
money can so regularly offer their
extremely valuable services for rates
that are less for rates about hour less
than what they are worth it's a
wonderful gift horse and I want to look
at in its mouth
peace Lucy it's the first time I've ever
seen a moose looking into the mouth of a
horse but there we go it's good stuff
Hank I have an answer to this question
because I wrote to my therapist friend
and I asked her this question and she
said that it's because they like helping
people yeah there is occasionally some
government funding for some people to
get therapy or some health insurance
funding for some people to get therapy
and that can affect the rates but in a
lot of cases it's because therapists
feel strongly about their mission and so
they take less money
I do think on that front it is the
responsibility of those of us who can
afford to pay full rate to ask
therapists what their full rate is and
to pay oh yeah it is it is a way in
which people can make a decision service
providers in this case therapists can
make a decision to have a sliding scale
to charge more to people who can afford
to pay it so that they can charge less
to the people who can't and sometimes
that may even
mean making less that month than they
otherwise would but but ultimately I
think that people get into into that
line of work not to get rich but to make
people's lives better and also if you're
in school there are often times there
are therapists who work for or at the
school who can who can be a little less
expensive than them finding someone
outside of that system yeah or even free
depending depending on the school you go
to Hank what is the what is the avocado
update who is winning avocado m-- or
avocado
well it's about 75% 25% John so there's
a pretty clear winner and unsurprisingly
for me it's avocado but Mike Rugnetta
asks an important question he says well
is it part of a complex of many adjacent
live in avocados no it is a good point
no it is a dome-shaped home called
avocado and once again as is sometimes
the case the majority is dead wrong
today's podcast is brought to you by
avocados avocado
clearly the superior avocado joke this
podcast has also brought to you by the
Federalist Papers they are a thing oh my
god this bad guys is also brought to you
by fancy Mac fancy Mac just throw
everything in a pot and finally this
podcast is brought to you by 23 flavors
but even more ingredients it's dr.
pepper sorry I was having a sip of dr.
pepper he could I was like did that one
just land real flat no apparently it
landed nice and fizzy we also have a
real sponsor today it's squares this
square space allows you to make a
beautiful website it really is I mean
you can go to John Green Comm if you
want to no you can't because I don't own
John Green Comm you can go to John Green
books calm if you want to see an example
of a great Squarespace website you can
go to John Green Comm and see an
excellent example of a guy who wants to
sell you homes
see in Mississippi you could also go to
Hank green calm if you want to see the
Squarespace website but Squarespace has
all kinds of templates allowing you to
build awesome awesome websites for
instance you could get avocados calm
probably or avocados Jack I just checked
I was there and you can't get off a
condo oh that's terrible
can you get avocado no who are these
people
well I'm sure the dot biz is still
available and believe you me I intend to
turn it into a business whatever your
idea is even if it's homes made out of
avocado you can build it with
Squarespace and you can head over to
Squarespace calm for a free trial when
you're ready to launch you can use the
offer code dear Hank or if you want to
the offer code Dear John and save 10%
off your first purchase of a website or
domain once again that offer code is
dear John that's the one to use the also
dear Hank will also work just to be very
clear think it dream it make it with
Squarespace thanks again to Squarespace
and again that offer code is Dear John I
think avakov
dot net is available this next question
comes from Ian who asks dear mrs. M
Messrs green whatever that is you Sears
seekers I've been working before day
week instead of five for the past
several months now and I really like it
but lately I've been obsessively
wondering about one thing if you work a
four-day week instead of five do you
still get a hump day or is the time
between the second and third days the
hump I know this kind of doesn't matter
at all but I would appreciate some
insight there is no letter e in E in
know that's a great point E and great
point
point yeah I mean Ian if we only
answered questions that mattered this
podcast would have ended years ago it
would be it would be no fun at all do
not apologize for asking your stupid
question the answer is that Wednesday is
still the hump day it's just that you
wake up on Thursday morning thinking I'm
in the second half but oh my god I'm in
the fourth quarter
I like that I like that that way you get
to participate in culture as well like
you don't get to just have here like
everybody still has a five-day workweek
I know that some people don't but
practically everybody does and you need
to participate in the rest of the world
along with the rest of the world so you
just need to call Wednesday the hump day
it is what it is and and then yeah you
get over that hump and suddenly it's
fricking your Friday no except that you
still have Friday as your Friday I think
so you still have to be like TGIF
because I'm not at work today Friday is
still Friday good okay yeah I guess
that's you've made everything very
confusing this is why it's so hard to
change things John yes this is why this
is why corporations refuse to move to a
four-day work week Hank because of the
hump day issue that is what's that is
what's chaining people to their desks
here in late-stage capitalism the hump
day problem it's all the weight of the
little things you know that's why we're
still like in miles per hour in America
that's why you know I solve that problem
what by waking up tomorrow morning
Canadian is wake up Canadian comma
failable because if not you Squarespace
to get it use the Africa Dear John wake
up Canadian calm you can use it to sell
visas I think actually Canada does
functionally sell visas uh yeah they've
gotten more expensive lately I mean
whatever they cost it's a steal but do I
have to pay for health care now this
next question comes from satchel we
solved this problem E and you're welcome
satchel writes Dear John and Hank are
books really a window into another world
as we've been told
or are they more of a distorted mirror
that reflects our own thanks satchel
satchel I think ok I think we'll just
ask the question and not answer it I
think that was the question asked is
doing its work in all of our heads and I
don't I I don't think that we need to
say anything we'll just have a 5 minutes
of silence so we can all think about
that one I mean I have an answer ok now
I feel I feel like I need to take some
time with that my answer is porque no
los dos
Spanish I'm so good at it when I speak
Spanish to my son who learns in Spanish
and his fluent in Spanish when I speak
Spanish to Henry he just looks at me
blankly yeah yeah why not both I think
we can have both it is a mirror into
another world in that that world isn't
as a peculiar and upsetting distortion
of our own no not always upsetting maybe
it maybe it makes us look back at our
own world and see how peculiar and
distorted it itself is I don't know
we're going too deep Hank we've got to
pull out we've got to pull out quickly
that's well I didn't want to talk about
it all right next question I thought it
was a beautiful question dear Hank of
John I just started a new job and when
one of my co-workers asked if I was in a
relationship I said yes I have a
boyfriend
however that is old small lie I actually
have a girlfriend I'm also a girl it
felt like more of a lie to say I was
single and I wasn't like ready to come
out at my new job my parents don't even
know and we've been a couple for over a
year now my co-workers keep inviting my
boyfriend to come over to social events
for work how do I get out of this
gracefully pumpkins in penguins
Anonymous Oh God
I have mostly wanted to ask this
question because I want to highlight how
it is still difficult to be different in
our society yeah it's difficult to be
different in our society and also when
somebody asks you a question like that
it's it it kind of almost forces you to
share information that you might not
want to share at your workplace and
there's always this tension between you
know wanting your workplace to be a
place where people you know feel
comfortable and they can be themselves
and they can talk about their lives and
they can you know become friends and
have real relationships but also you
know wanting people to be able to be
private if they want to be mm-hmm and
yeah I I think the problem comes in when
you when you ask the question rather
than waiting for somebody to volunteer
that information and and I don't think
that you did anything wrong here and I
just
I don't think that there really is a
graceful exit I would double down on a
lie
personally because that's always my
strategy oh yeah yeah just just be like
and here's my boyfriend but yeah I broke
up with my boyfriend now we got a new I
got a girlfriend now that's what
happened you could do that or you could
just like you could just say like oh
yeah no I don't think I said I had a
boyfriend I think I said I had a
girlfriend and they could be like no I
don't think you did and you could be
like yeah I'm pretty sure I did
that'll probably in the conversation
disagree who knows I don't think there's
a tape take it take it like Trump's
lawyer just be like really you think I
don't know that's what you say I say it
everything right
yeah alternative facts just say just
just just look that in the eye say
shrug and say alternative facts and move
on with your life if not a lie it's an
alternative fact you have your facts I
have my facts who knows which facts are
true this next question comes from Lou
who asks dear Hank and John I just
received an email about opening a
confirmation link I'm pretty sure it's
spam and may contain a virus but it's
from Ryan should I open it surely
someone named Ryan wouldn't try to lead
me astray unless it's a fake Ryan what
do you think your help is urgently
needed Thank You Lou I don't know John
could have Ryan mislead someone can you
be a fake Ryan if that even allowed
I mean first off half the people who
write in to us as Ryan's are fake Ryan's
so we know that fake Ryan's are an
epidemic problem in our social order I
just want to pause here midway through
the answer to this question and say
hello welcome new listeners yeah exactly
there's this long-standing inside joke
that I myself no longer get about Ryan's
one time somebody wrote in and they said
their name was Ryan and they they
repeated the name Ryan like six times
and I don't even know how it became a
thing but it's a thing and there you go
it doesn't mean that you can trust
everybody named Ryan in fact I can off
the top of my head think of several
people named Ryan who I don't trust a
wick but but what if they all woke up
Canadian tomorrow uh I mean are there
any famous Canadian Ryan's well of
course Ryan where do you see the old all
the famous yeah both and also Ryan
Gosling is Canadian is Ryan Reynolds
Canadian or did I mix him up with Ryan
Gosling for the seventeen million times
Canadian Ryan Reynolds Kelly God thank
God that makes me feel much better
whoo dodged a bullet there yeah Ryan
Reynolds is a really good-looking guy
I'm on the Google right now you're
looking at that that that that jawline
and I'm remembering when I saw him in
real life and I was just dumbfounded
it's weird when you see people that are
so attractive that you're you're like oh
yeah I shouldn't be allowed even if he
weren't famous
oh by the way if you google Ryan
Reynolds Canadian and you google image
search the first picture is him between
two Mounties oh yeah those who don't
know that's the Royal Canadian Mounted
Police like why didn't they just put him
in one of those outfits he could be an
honorary Mountie for a day and I would
Excel the only problem with being
Canadian is that if I change my
nationality I really want to change it
to a nationality where I have a
snowball's chance in hell of getting
knighted can Canadians be knighted
because that's my biggest dream uh I
think they can John look it up all right
you answer the next question while I
investigate this question can commence
oh my god Hank the first the the
Google's first suggested search - can
Canadians is benighted the second -
second is work in the UK the third is
own guns and the fourth is win Powerball
Oh also I want to I want to report that
if you google famous Canadians and do an
image search
Gosling is number 12 really who's number
one uh Jim Carrey oh I didn't know he
was Canadian and then number two is join
the rock Johnson which doesn't seem
right cuz he thinks that Canady there's
no way there's no way the rock is
Canadian the rock is Canadian question
Mark Twain's dad is Canadian no okay so
he is like is dual citizenship that's
yeah yes Canadian blood in him oh okay
hold on Hank Hank I have an update I
have an update the British government
accidentally knighted two people in 2001
who were Canadian and the Canadian
government freaked out the Prime
Minister of Canada objected quote in the
strongest terms and said the planet
Venus has a long-standing policy that
prevents Canadians from accepting titles
well in that case I guess I'll just move
to England that's awesome and weird that
that they had to be like hey no I have a
very shy of an objection to you honoring
one of our citizens in this particular
way find a different way Hank I just
realized that we forgot to read our
project for awesome message somebody
donated to the project for awesome to
get us to say this which we are now
going to say it was Rene from Brooklyn
who donated for us to say this to
Kimberly I would like you to do a shout
out to Kimberly she's been a fan of
yours for a long time and she's
recommended you to me and we even went
to Boston to see you at nerdcon
nerdfighteria she loves you guys and
always watches your videos and it will
mean a lot just for you guys to shout
her out she's a true nerdfighter so
Thank You Kimberly you are the bee's
knees you rock my socks you are awesome
what other parts of bees can people be
the eyes you're the bee's eyes YUM
you're the bee's wings that's a nice
thing to think about just you're the
bees honey making parts oh I don't I
don't know if I want to be an excretory
organ
I think we'll just leave that there can
move on great Hank it's time to move on
to the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
okay excellent exciting John what the
news from AFC Wimbledon and I think for
once is good oh my god Hank
I almost barf I did I was so sick to my
stomach
Nancy Walden were playing against
Charlton Hank at the exact same time
that Liverpool were trying to get a
place in the Champions League
semi-finals against Manchester City and
Liverpool had to lose by less than three
and they gave up a goal in the second
minute and then I started to feel like I
might barf and then AFC Wimbledon it's
almost worse for me when AFC Wimbledon
are winning than when they're not in the
last minute of the first half in
stoppage time the Montserrat e'en Messi
the the Ronaldo of the Caribbean wild
Taylor scored a goal to put Wimbledon 1
nil up which meant that for the last 45
minutes of that game I had to feel
constant terror I've started to believe
that it's bad luck for me to watch the
live stream of the games on my phone on
the appetite that I paid a lot a lot a
lot of money for so I was listening to
the radio broadcast while watching the
second half of the Liverpool Man City
game and oh my god I mean even though
Charlton never had a shot on target I
was in constant gnawing fear that at any
moment
Wimbledon were going to give up this
lead but they didn't there were six
endless minutes of stoppage time but
Wimbledon emerged with a 1 nil victory
and after their 1-1 draw against
Scunthorpe which was very close to being
a win and if that had been a win we'd be
in great shape
but that means that now we have 46
points with five games remaining meaning
that we are 6 points probably from
having enough points to stay in Ligue 1
for another season we need to win two of
our last five games to probably maybe
one win and two draws would do it maybe
one win in one draw would do it it's
hard to know but we are four points
clear of the relegation zone right now
however one of the teams in the
relegation zone has a game in hand
against us which means that potentially
we're only one point clear if they win
that game it is very tight at the bottom
of the league one table this season
terrifyingly tight there are still
probably eight teams that could go into
those last two relegation spots the
franchise currently applying its trade
in Milton Keynes was briefly out of the
relegation zone is now back in it 42
points after 41 games we've got 46
points after 41 games so five games to
go in the season we need two wins two
wins we just need two wins and I think
we'll be okay oh god it's so scary yeah
at least you're not burry or bury or
whoever that is at the very bottom with
30 points
that's very true they're gonna make it
they are probably gonna be relegated
like officially relegated next week and
you want to know why that's great news
for us why and we play them on the last
game of the season okay and so do you
not play them then no we still play them
but hopefully they'll be like yeah we
got nothing to play for let's start a
bunch of 12 year olds okay
that is great news I don't run I don't
know I kind of felt like that should
have happened with a recent game but I
don't know how it works I guess
everybody wants to be higher in the
table even if they aren't gonna be at
the tippy tippy tippy top but if you're
definitely getting relegated you might
be like well let's not hurt our good
good folk our good boys I don't I don't
know I'm just hoping I don't know it's
this is I this this season has been
exceptionally stressful it's it's much
harder it's much harder than to be
around the relegation zone for the
entire season then than it is to be
looking up the table yeah I mean and the
other thing is that you very recently
had a game where you were up by 0.4 like
for like 60 minutes of the game 81
minutes 81 minutes of the game will
nightingale scored in the fourth minute
and Scunthorpe equalized in the 85th
minute it was excruciating
in that game I was actually traveling so
I was in an airport for a large part
it and I was just pacing and my kids
were watching me and when Scunthorpe
gave up i was just it's heartbreaking so
hopefully we'll stay up I don't know
what else to say with six points from
five games let's go up the dawn's pink
what's the news from Mars the news from
Mars it's gonna it's hard for me for
like the foreseeable future to not talk
about the Mars insight Lander which will
be launching very soon but in assuming
that there will be other episodes of
your Hank of John I'm gonna save that
one and give a double smaller news which
is regarding one the CEO of Boeing who
has said previously that he believes
strongly that they will beat
SpaceX to Mars has come out with a
timeline and says that he thinks that he
could get that Boeing could get humans
to Mars within a decade now I don't know
if that means the decade of the 2020s or
if he means within a decade which would
make it very close to our timeline for
keeping the name of the podcast dear
Hank and John but in any case that's
great news for me and also I think
humanity he also says though this is a
little bit you know that it would
require quote consistent reliable
funding which is something that boy big
projects at NASA very rarely get so
that's a question mark but it is nice to
see why we do not have at the moment
though we might end up there a political
space race we've got a bit of a sort of
capitalist space race going on here
between Boeing and SpaceX and even some
other contractors so they're fighting
the fight and I want them to I want them
to fight it John the other news is that
John Krasinski who was Jim in the office
has become a pretty hot ticket director
these days with a film that everybody
liked a lot that I'm not gonna watch cuz
it's a horror movie called a quiet place
but he's been signed on to direct a
sci-fi movie called life on Mars in
which the number of people live on Mars
and the plot twist is that one day a
woman discovers that she can breathe the
atmosphere and that's cool and I like
Mars movies John interestingly that
screenplay was based on a short story
written by Cecil Castelluccio why a
writer who I admire very much so it all
comes full circle
I should add Hank that I've been
thinking about something recently which
is that so the first Mars rover was made
basically out of earth right I mean it
was made out of things that we got from
Earth and humans behind have made out of
Earth yeah yeah
so yeah earth and atmosphere was the
Mars rover the first time that Earth has
ever gone to Mars oh no bummer
well yeah Eartha the Earth has gone to
Mars in like little pieces so in the
same way that we have found Martian
meteorites on earth there are earth okay
well once we once we start sending
people maybe it'll be the first time
that organic matter has gone from Earth
to Mars or ya know there is a there is
that panspermia theory that that pieces
of life get knocked off of planets and
that's that's one way that life could
get spread around the solar system or
even the galaxy the mechanism of that
whether or not that's actually possible
is is very much up in the air and it's
sort of hard to imagine life taking very
long interplanetary trips in the way
that all of those those meteorite trips
would be and then also flap flapping
themselves through an atmosphere onto a
planet and getting all hot and burned up
and stuff right okay well I was thinking
that would be cool but it turns out that
as usual the way I imagined it is not
the way that it is what have we learned
today we learned that a hollowed-out
avocado that you live in is only an
avocado if it is part of a complex of
many adjacent live in avocados we
learned that Hank does not want to be an
excretory organ we learned that
Canadiens cannot be knighted and if you
try you get yourself in some trouble and
of course we learned that Hank does not
know who it's a Federalist Papers are
that important doesn't feel like it
could be that important it's pretty
important
if you yeah I mean it's an important
part of American history and American
government but let's just move on to the
outro hey John
thank you for podcasting with me
everybody listening out there if you
want to send us questions that's the
only way we can make the podcast we
appreciate everybody who sends in
questions and are sorry for the ones
that we can't answer but you can send us
questions at Hank and John at gmail.com
or on Twitter at John is John Green and
Hank is Hank green
I am also Hank I don't know I referred
myself in the third person this podcast
is edited by Nicholas Jenkins it's
produced by rosianna halse rojas and
Sheridan Gibson are a head of community
and communications is Victoria bon
giorno she's in charge all the stuff
that gets split up on that patreon at
patreon.com slash for your Hank and John
it's a resource for people who give us
money but also for people who don't
there isn't very much private content on
there and we appreciate everybody who
can donate to get this weekend Ryan's in
their ears or just anything that they
can give which helps to fund all of our
educational content that we make it
complexly so thanks for Victoria for
Handel and Matt and thanks to everybody
who supports us on patreon the music
that you're hearing right now and at the
beginning of the podcast is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]